quelques jours après l'annonce
controversée de sa candidature Éric
Zemmour veut marquer son entrée en scène
devant des milliers de partisans ils
annoncent la création de son mouvement
politique
de notre pays pour le retrouver
des cris des applaudissements dans le
cadre d'un événement également marqué
par des épisodes dans du des
journalistes brièvement mise à l'abri
par la sécurité et des affrontements
entre partisans et militant antiraciste
qui se sont invités dans la salle rien
pour empêcher le candidat de présenter
ses priorités
[Musique]
en attendant ses messages sur
l'immigration et d'identité Éric Zemmour
veut séduire les électeurs de l'extrême
droite mais aussi ceux de la droite
traditionnelle
La Cantina fraîchement élu du parti les
républicains dans ce message ah c'est
partisans qui pourrait être tenté
d'appuyer Éric Zemmour ou Marine Le Pen
être convaincant vous savez les
marchands de peur ne sont jamais
efficace dans l'action de l'autre côté
du Spectre politique la gauche et aussi
divisé sur la ligne de départ le Parti
socialiste et les écologistes mais aussi
la France insoumise de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui tenait également le grand
rassemblement électoral dimanche
reprogrammer une grande fois de plus
dans la France ce n'est pas à l'extrême
droite la France c'est la sécurité
sociale c'est la santé publique
seulement si passion c'est l'école c'est
la recherche je le partage après de 4
mois du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle le paysage politique est
mort seul et c'est sans compter plus au
centre le président sortant Emmanuel
Macron dans la candidature n'ai toujours
pas officialiser nombre élevé d'aspirant
président qui rend l'élection
imprévisible un impact majeur parce que
ça fait que mécaniquement la barre pour
se qualifier pour le deuxième tour elle
est beaucoup plus basse c'était hier que
vous avez la plupart vous n'avez que
Emmanuel Macron qui est un niveau
supérieur à 20 % donc beaucoup de
candidats peuvent se dire oui j'ai une
chance de me qualifier en avril les
candidats de vent aussi faire face à un
autre anniversaire la tentation de
l'abstention une option qui a pris de
l'ampleur
sélection Bouvier Auclair Radio-Canada
Paris